Oh my God Youtubers, we finally got some more
Spider-Man homecoming that just pretty much
guarantees is a can be dropping the official
trailer with Rogue one in a couple weeks was
out of him.
So this is Brazil, comic con.
It was basically like a short clip from Spiderman's
perspective he starts swinging around and
he's talking to happy Hogan Jon Favreau's
back
you guys remember him from the iron man movie
he's technically only iron man's driver, but
he's kind of like the confidant which actually
reminds me I'm actually going to be doing
and Iron Man Spiderman giveaway so all you
have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
comixology gift certificate for about $30
be sure to turn alerts on because there's
going to be a whole bunch of Spider-Man dropping
really soon.
They were able to convince Jon Favreau to
come out of hiding.
He's been directing movies so it's not like
he's been doing nothing, I know everybody's
hoping that is gonna come back in direct Iron
Man for eventually you know who knows that
led up happening, but hopefully the marvel
illuminati and Robert Downey Junior can convince
them but then they jump to a couple other
clips.
There's Tony Stark giving Spiderman a giant
suit upgrade in this big start take brief
case then you see him jump off a building
with the classic webbing underneath his arms,
so they're going for some super deep cuts
with marbles version of Spider-Man.
It's going to be so awesome.
I know it doesn't seem like there's a whole
lot of Iron Man the movie just the way people
of been talking about it, you probably heard
about the way Marvel is treating the hold
in all these films like their giving him what
is essentially his own movie just spread out
over a couple different movies because of
the weird right situation with Universal obviously
they don't have that problem with Iron Man.
It just that Robert Downey Junior is waiting
for the right story to come along and he is
so expensive that they want to make sure if
the gonna do another Iron Man story that is
just gonna blow up Captain America Civil War
style and for the most part, Iron Man is kind
of in a low moment right now so it looks like
he's throwing himself into men touring young
Peter Parker S will not go when we have here
Richard to come ashore Salvation Army if not
full-blown adopting him.
I don't think they'll ever do that but though
do so flirt with that idea like the make you
feel like Tony Stark is emotionally adopting
Spiderman just like Spider-Man will emotionally
adopt Tony Stark, you can just imagine the
headline aging lonely billionaire adopted
by widow and nephew.
So you see a lot of Iron Man films you can
imagine what his scenes are going to be like
in the film like that seen in Civil War was
so telling the way you do it was kind of funny
but to be a little offhanded casual that there
was also a lot of heart in it to like Iron
Man's been through a lot of ship so has Peter
Parker as of now like he starts to tell the
uncle Ben story when he first meets Tony.
But they kinda stop a short, but also in that
same way, the kind of using Dr. strange very
sparingly and other people's films, the same
thing can happen with Iron Man and the whole
kit just I like the whole thing is gonna be
a much much bigger part of Thor Ragnarok because
there been so little of them so far, and there's
been so much of Iron Man be started talk about
how Peter Parker resembles Tony Stark just
a little bit.
He's a future scientist.
This shirt that he's wearing just gives you
an idea for the tone of the humor to the physics
is theoretical, but the fun is real.
So he just like a branch off of the Tony Stark
tree.
I can't wait to see their scenes together
just see them try to out quit each other Spiderman
is King of quipping but Robert Downey Jr's
Iron Man is King of quipping in the marble
cinematic universe, so they jump between a
couple of the other people in the movies.
Some of the villages like some of the big
action set pieces.
There was a vulture action set piece that
was in the comic con trailer they cut up a
little bit of that in there Iron Man is going
to have to help him out, just because the
shocker is also in the movie there was a little
bit of Michelle net leads the other people
at the school like flash Thompson and that
little bit from the funny bank heist save
where he takes down people who are dressed
up like the avengers is like this really hilarious
heist were like a bunch of thugs dressed up
like the core avengers from the first avengers
film of Spiderman's like I just got done hanging
out with you guys.
You were definitely not my friends.
So he'll have like a couple small funny saves
then you have the really big vulture stuff
is going on in the movie but I just love the
idea that Tony Stark is helping to make him
whole Spiderman again given a bunch of different
versions of the character before there been
a lot of stories about how Andrew Garfield
felt like he failed the character which is
kind of a bummer but I think you know what
Marvel and Sony are intending to do with this
arrangement is just bring back a lot of depth
and meaning to the character like a deeper
message Andrew Garfield's criticism of his
own version of Spiderman was it was kind of
hollow but he was perpetuating that type of
Michael Bay filming with all show no feeling
behind it.
So far in a Marvel is just trying to infuse
a lot of the emotion you felt like the first
time you read a Spider-Man comic into this
movie.
So that's why feel like we should all be freaking
out about it but yet there's gonna be like
a ton of really awesome action scenes in it
to in this is only the first movie in a trilogy.
So if you didn't know they did confirm that
Spiderman is getting a new trilogy that will
follow him through high school.
They haven't fully explain how the timelines
going to work only that Kevin Feige was likening
it to the Harry Potter franchise the way it
followed him through school right up to the
end.
So he'll be graduating in that final film
but that doesn't mean that he's not can be
doing avengers stuff in between.
We have the infinity war films, so they'll
be all kinds of stuff happening it's just
a Spiderman's age will keep him a teenager
through these films so you not to get like
a 16-year-old Spiderman in Spider-Man homecoming
which is actually where picks up he's a sophomore
high school cut to the next movie where he
is 26 with a 5 o'clock shadow not the stop
Oliver Toby McGuire because actually really
did enjoy those movies when I saw them but
they did joke about putting some dancing in
the movie, just because Tom Holland is actually
a really good performer and is actually very
acrobatic, so given that the homecoming dance.
Spider-Man homecoming all these things bleed
together there might be like a little bit
of dancing somewhere in the film and if you
have watch the other Spiderman movies even
like the Toby McGuire movies.
You know that the role that Norman Osborne
occupies in Spiderman's life because of Harry
Osborn even becomes this big bill is kind
of like an evil version of Tony Stark.
So what they done.
Spider-Man homecoming is a given that role
to Michael Keaton's vulture, but that doesn't
mean that he is like Norman Osborne he just
a big villain who constructs of flight suit
like that's how his wings work, they just
decided that Marvel is just gonna floes a
lot from Stark tech it's all technology based
on a lot of metahuman's or even mutants and
because they can't use the word mutants because
of the Fox films so that doesn't mean that
there never going to do green goblin.
It just means they wanted to do different
characters that they haven't done before in
this first new Spider-Man fell in fun fact,
if you want to know why they redid the origin
story like the essentially did the exact same
story.
When they rebooted Spiderman with Andrew Garfield
Kevin Feige actually clarified that that was
a rights issue that was part of the way that
Sony was allowed to keep making Spiderman
films they had to do an origin story.
So it's kind of ridiculous, but that just
kind of the way that contracts work out with
big Hollywood studios.
So thankfully now because of this Marvel arrangement.
They don't have to redo the uncle Ben origin
story you pick up with Peter being Spiderman
for a while though probably address uncle
Ben like he will be completely absent from
the film the nuts can a redo the origin story
of again, so just reminder that the Spiderman
trailer is supposed to be attached to Rogue
one that's what everybody seems to be saying
I haven't seen any official confirmation from
Marvel but they typically don't confirm stuff
like that like usually they don't comment,
but that's gonna be in two weeks and I will
be doing a bunch of Rogue one videos to but
James Gunn also revealed that they finished
the new guardians of the Galaxy trailer.
He did not confirm when they're dropping that
it might also drop with Star Wars Rogue one.
So what can happen next is I'll post a new
Rick and Morty video then I'll post a video
for next season's big flash arrow legends
big crossover.
So get hype is can be really good weekend
is a whole bunch of comic book stuff happening
this weekend while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for all the big
DC week videos that I did for the big crossover
and you can click here to rewatch the guardians
of the Galaxy to trailer.
So everybody high five I'll see you guys in
a little bit!